ATTORNEY FOR GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN.
THAT’S OUR OTHER MAJOR BREAKING
NEWS.
WE’VE BEEN SAYING THIS IS THEIR
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER,
CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
NOW WE KNOW BARACK OBAMA,
JOE BIDEN, SUSAN RICE, SALLY
YATES, MR. SUPER PATRIOT JIM
COMEY, LOWEST HONOR ON EARTH
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED.
WHAT WE’RE ABOUT TO SHOW YOU, IT
SHOULD ANGER EVERY AMERICAN, IT
SHOULD SHAKE YOU TO YOUR CORE,
IT SURE TO SEND A SHIVER UP YOUR
SPINE IF YOU LOVE OUR
CONSTITUTION AND YOU LOVE
FREEDOM AND YOU BELIEVE IN THE
RULE OF LAW BECAUSE ALL OF THESE
HIGH-RANKING BAD ACTORS NOW MUST
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE OR WE CAN
KISS THIS GREAT REPUBLIC
GOOD-BYE.
THAT’S HOW SERIOUS IT IS TONIGHT
BASED ON WHAT WE CAN REPORT AND
THAT IS NEWLY UNCOVERED
BOMBSHELL, HANDWRITTEN NOTES
FROM PETER STRZOK HIMSELF
REVEALING THE SICK, THE TWISTED
ORIGINS OF THE GENERAL FLYNN
PROBE IN A MEMO DETAILING THE
INFAMOUS, REMEMBER, WE TALKED
ABOUT THAT TIME LINE,
JANUARY 5TH MEETING IN THE
OVAL OFFICE, THE WHITE HOUSE.
STILL A LOT OF IT REDACTED AND
I’M TOLD WHEN WE GET THAT
INFORMATION IT’S EVEN WORSE.
PETER STRZOK DETAILING THE
BRAINSTORMING SESSION BETWEEN
OBAMA, BIDEN, SALLY YATES AND
OTHERS, THIS WAS ONE DAY AFTER
THE FLYNN CASE WAS DONE, SHOT,
CLOSED BECAUSE THEY HAD NO
EVIDENCE OF ANYTHING
INAPPROPRIATE, THIS MEETING
FOCUSING ON HOW TO DESTROY
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN
ACCORDING TO PETER STRZOK AND
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY SAYING
"THEY APPEAR LEGIT."
THEY DID NOTHING WRONG, THE
INVESTIGATION PROVED, THE
TRANSCRIPTS SHOW, NOTHING WAS
EVER WRONG ABOUT THAT CALL.
THAT DID NOT STOP THE DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE JOE BIDEN
WHO BROUGHT UP THE LOGAN ACT TO
GO AFTER GENERAL FLYNN.
NOW REMEMBER, THAT IS THE LAW
FROM 1799 THAT’S NEVER BEEN
USED.
KEEP IN MIND, ALL OF THIS AFTER
THEY EXONERATED A 33 YEAR
VETERAN AND WAR HERO.
OBAMA CLEARLY APPROVING, SAYING
THESE ARE UNUSUAL TIMES, THAT
OBAMA IN THE OVAL OFFICE SAYING
THAT HIS TEAM SHOULD "HAVE THE
RIGHT PEOPLE ON IT."
OBAMA WANTED ANTI-TRUMP ZEALOTS
WHO ARE READY AND WILLING TO
TAKE DOWN GENERAL FLYNN PAGE I
BE TELLING THE TRUMP TRANSITION
TEAM ARE NOT TELLING THEM
THINGS?
NOW WE KNOW WHY THE SEVENTH
FLOOR, THE FBI THE DAY BEFORE
ALONG WITH PETER STRZOK DECIDED
TO REOPEN A CLOSED CASE AGAINST
GENERAL FLYNN AFTER IT WAS DEAD
IN THE WATER 24 HOURS EARLIER.
NOW WE KNOW WHY SUSAN RICE WROTE
THE BIGGEST EMAIL TO HERSELF ON
DONALD TRUMP’S INAUGURATION DAY
15 DAYS LATER, OBAMA’S LAST DAY
IN OFFICE SAYING "BARACK WANTED
EVERYTHING TO BE DONE BY THE
BOOK."
AND WE ALSO KNOW WHY SALLY YATES
WHEN SHE SPOKE TO THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
WE STARTED THIS INVESTIGATION IN
MARCH OF 2017, WE KNOW WHY LISA
PAGE TEXTED THAT OBAMA WANTS TO
KNOW EVERYTHING WE ARE DOING.
THIS ALL CAME FROM THE VERY TOP.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, OBAMA
LOYALIST AND THE DOJ WERE
SMEARING, DESTROYING ANYBODY IN
DONALD TRUMP’S ORBIT BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO UNDO A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
THEY THOUGHT THEY KNEW BETTER.
NOW WE KNOW WHY ROGER STONE HAD
A PREDAWN RAID IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT, 29 GUYS IN TACTICAL
GEAR AND CNN CAMERAS, WE KNOW
WHY, SAME WITH PAUL MANAFORT.
HE HAD A PREDAWN RAID IT’S
TAKING GUNS IN HIS WIFE’S FACE
AND THROWING HIM IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT SO HE MIGHT SAY
THINGS I WOULD GET HIM OFF THE
HOOK.
WHICH HE DIDN’T.
NOW WE KNOW WHY GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS WAS THREATENED WITH
YEARS IN PRISON WHEN ALL HE SAID
WAS I WOULD NEVER DO THAT,
NOBODY EVER TALKED TO RUSSIA.
THIS WAS ALL IN THE END OF THE
MEANS TO THE END.
THAT IS CALLED AN ATTEMPTED COUP
AND BY THE WAY, JOE BIDEN, ARE
YOU REALLY UNABLE TO REMEMBER
THAT JANUARY 5TH MEETING, WOULD
YOU OFFER UP THE LOGAN ACT AS A
MEANS OF PROSECUTING THE LIFE OF
GENERAL FLYNN OR ARE YOU JUST A
LIAR?
I’M BETTING YOU’RE A LIAR, TAKE
A LOOK.
>> WHAT DID YOU KNOW ABOUT THOSE
MOVES TO INVESTIGATE MICHAEL
FLYNN?
IT WAS THERE ANYTHING IMPROPER
DONE?
YOU DIDN’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
IT, YOU ARE REPORTED TO BE A
JANUARY 5TH 2017 MEETING WHERE
YOU AND THE PRESIDENT ARE
BRIEFED ON THE FBI’S PLAN TO
QUESTION.
MICHAEL FLYNN OVER THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TO HAVE WITH OUR
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR.
>> I THOUGHT YOU ASKED ME
WHETHER I HAD ANYTHING TO DO
WITH HIM BEING PROSECUTED, I’M
SORRY.
I WAS AWARE THAT THEY ASKED FOR
AN INVESTIGATION BUT THAT’S ALL
I KNOW.
I WAS NEVER PART OR HAD ANY
KNOWLEDGE OF ANY CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION IN TO MAKE INTO
FLYNN WHILE I WAS IN OFFICE,
PERIOD, NOT ONCE HAVE A TIME.
>> Sean: NOT A PART OF ANY
INVESTIGATION INTO FLYNN?
THAT’S A LIE.
NOT A PART OF THE LOGAN ACT?
WHEN
ASKED ABOUT THE LIBRARY NOT A
PART OF THE JANUARY 5TH MEETING?
THAT’S A LIE, JOE.
WHAT DID JOE KNOW?
WHAT DID BARACK KNOW, WHY DID
SALLY YATES KNOW?
AND WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT?
MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE THE WHEELS OF JUSTICE
MOVE PAINFULLY SLOW.
WE FIRST STARTED ON THIS WITH
UNMASKING, AND LEAVE ILLEGAL
SURVEILLANCE, I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW, EVER SINCE HIS PROGRAM AND
OUR ENSEMBLE CAST HERE EVERY
SINGLE NIGHT, WE’VE REPORTED TO
YOU THE TRUTH.
BY THE WAY MY SOURCES ARE
TELLING ME TONIGHT, THE DAM IS
ABOUT TO BURST WIDE OPEN AND
THAT TRUCK LOAD OF NEW EVIDENCE
IS ON THE WAY.
IT IS MADE REAL PROGRESS AND
THANK GOD, THIS CAN HAPPEN TO
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN.
NOBODY IN THIS COUNTRY IS SAFE.
TURNING THEM ON AMERICAN HEROES
LIKE GENERAL FLYNN, HE WAS A
HERO.
33 YEAR VETERAN, MULTIPLE TOURS
OF DUTY.
FOUR YEARS OF HIS LIFE WAS
RIPPED AWAY BY THE TOP SO-CALLED
LEADERS, THE 1% THAT ABUSE THEIR
POWER, HE LOST HIS HOUSE, HE
FACED BANKRUPTCY, THEY THREATEN
TO PUT HIS SON IN JAIL, USED AS
LEVERAGE EVEN THOUGH HE DIDN’T
FEEL LIKE HE WAS LYING, IN OTHER
WORDS, I HAVE TO SIGN THIS?
OR YOU’RE GOING TO GO AFTER MY
SON.
HE IMPALED HIMSELF AND DROVE ON
THE SWORD LIKE ANY GOOD, LOVING
FATHER WOULD DO.
ALL OF THIS BECAUSE OF HIS
POLITICAL CONNECTION TO
DONALD TRUMP.
THE COUNTRY’S VERY OWN
DEMOCRATIC, STATE RUN, THEY
CHEER FOR THE PERSECUTION OF
GENERAL FLYNN, WHETHER YOU AND
THE MOB ARE GOING TO APOLOGIZE,
THAT MEANS YOUR FAKE NEWS
NETWORK, RACHEL MADDOW, THAT
MEANS YOUR CONSPIRACY TV
NETWORK, THE NEW YORK TOILET
PAPER TIMES, THE WASHINGTON
COMPOST, ABC, NBC, CBS, YOU ALL
OWE GENERAL FLYNN A HUGE APOLOGY
FOR WHAT YOU SAID AND DID AND
YOUR LACK OF OBJECTIVITY AND
YOUR LIES ABOUT RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER.
>> DID FLYNN GO ROGUE, BY THE
WAY, WHEN HE SPOKE TO RUSSIA?
>>>> THE FACT IS, MICHAEL FLYNN
WOULD TRADE HIS COUNTRY.
>> MICHAEL FLYNN BETRAYED THE
NATION.
>> AFTER TWO HOURS OF A JUDGE